hello everyone welcome
i am normal malapaq i am a visualization
developer here at wolfram research
and today my talk is about
geo visualization in the wolfram
language
before i begin a few housekeeping points
if you have any questions please type
them into the
chat session and i'll take a look at
them
after the presentation if you're
listening to this talk live
there is a virtual office hours with
visualization developers after this talk
so if you're interested i would
encourage you to go to that session
so with that out of the way let me
begin my presentation um
about geo visualization geo
visualization in the wolfram language
unifies geographic functionality with
data visualization features
and so um here's a list of the things
that um
i will go through in this talk not
necessarily in this order
but they're just here to give you a
sense of some of the
topics that i would like to cover so
we'll start off by
looking at some basic geographics
example
um example so that you know
we can set the stage for talking about
geo visualization functions
then we'll take a look at all the geo
visualization functions that we have
and we'll take a look at them from the
point of view of the data
that they seek to visualize
throughout this talk we will take a look
at the different options that we have
that control not just the the geographic
layer of the visualization but also the
data visualization layer
and then finally i'll point out some of
the
new features and updates for jio
visualization functions that we've been
working on for the upcoming
release of the wolfram language
okay so
to start off we have a very rich and
deep
geocomputation in geographics
functionality in the world language so
we seek to
leverage those to construct
the different geo-visualization
functions so if we wanted to
visualize let's say city
using geographics um how would we do it
so one way would be to get the
information about
city into the wolfram language
via the wolfram knowledgebase
and so we can do that by hitting control
equals
in a notebook environment and typing in
berlin
and accepting the recommendation that we
get from the knowledge base
and that fetches the entity information
about berlin
now we can feed that into geoposition
which computes the
latitude and longitude for berlin
and then what we are doing here is to
ask geographics to plot that location
and so geographics will
draw a map of the location
the area of berlin and then we've asked
geographics to draw a disk around that
location of a certain radius in a
certain opacity and so you see this
sort of light gray disc that is plotted
around berlin
now we can also do the same thing with a
polygon so
we can use entity framework to get the
polygon information
for germany and when we plot that using
geographics you
see a map with germany highlighted
so these are some of the basic building
blocks
um for doing geographics and this is
what we
use for building different geo
visualization functions so as long as we
want to do something simple
like this it's not a problem to use
geographics but
once we want to plot more information
and layer more data on top of these
graphics
then it can get complicated
quite quickly and so to deal with that
we have
a suite of geo-visualization functions
and so these functions are built on top
of the geographic's
functionality and we also leverage
the different data plots that we have
and so we
layer the geographic functionality in
the
in the data visualization functionality
and build these geometrization functions
and so the names of these functions
should give you some idea of what
visualization functions will be using
to make these plots and so we have gls
plot which is based off of list plot
geodensity plot and list density plot
and so forth
so we'll take a look at some of the
examples for these plots but before we
do that
let's classify these plots into
[Music]
into different categories based on the
kinds of data that
they handle this is important because
in order to unify geographics and data
visualization functions
[Music]
two of the tools that we have are the
data specification for these plots and
the different
options that control the different
layers of the plots so we'll be taking a
look at both of them
but let's start with classifying the
different
data specifications so if we wanted to
do a geoplot
the data can be categorized into four
broad
classes the first one is locations this
is
virtually identical to the geographics
example that i showed you so we can
specify the locations either as a
geoposition
or an entity or a graphics primitive
like polygon
or a geoprimitive like geodesk
and we can use all of them pretty much
directly in geographics
but we have some functions that
use that in geo visualization as well so
we'll take a look at that
now if we wanted to add more information
to this basic
location information the way to do that
is to
one way to do that is to associate
each of those positions with a scalar
value and so that
brings us to a second class of
data um
that will be handled by geoviz functions
and that is scalar values and locations
so here the locations again are
specified as geoposition and entity in
polygon
but each of those positions are then
associated with a
scalar value or a color for certain
plots or quantity
and the last line
in that specifies
you know how we can do the association
of a list of positions with a list of
values
for convenience
we can of course also associate the
positions
with not just a scale value but a vector
value and so that brings us to the third
class
of data that we have and so we can have
geovectors which in themselves have
a position in the vector associated with
those positions
so we have geovector geovector e and u
or we can have a list of vectors or an
association of location with vector
and there are a class of plots that deal
with these
and then finally we have location
intensity of points which is a different
way of
visualizing locations and so
these are kind of identical to
what we have for the locations except
for
the last line there which i'll come to
in a minute but
these will pass through some
visualization functions
which will give us information about the
density
of the locations and so forth the last
one
that we have is an association where we
associate each of these locations with
the weight and so we can visualize the
location intensities based on the
weights
okay so those are the the four broad
categorizations
of uh data for the different plots so
now let's look at the different plots
and how each of these plots
handle these data types
so the first one is locations so this is
very similar to
geographics and so here we have
um the same kind of locations from
geoposition
and entity that are being passed into
geolist plot
and gls plot is going to take
the geoposition in and plot it as a
point
and so is um and so is the entity being
plotted as
a point we can also feed them
geodisc or disk and they will
plot those primitives um overlaid on top
of the
geographics so here
this is pretty much identical to what
geographics does but here you can
already see
a small difference in that we are able
to use
geo labels as an option and geolabels
is able to figure out in the second case
where we have
entity as one of the ways to specify the
location
it has enough that that entity has
enough information for gls plot to
figure out that it's able to do
something intelligent
with geo labels and it's able to name
label the point the location of that
city with the name of the city
this of course can be done in
geographics too using geostyling etc
but from the point of view of
data visualization it's more convenient
and more natural to be able to use
options that we're used to with
data plotting functions
jillis plot of course also is able to
plot a list of values
and a list of locations and so here
we have the capital cities of europe
as a list and that is being plotted by
gls
plot as points corresponding to the
locations of those capital cities
gls plot can also plot polygons so if we
ask yellow's plot to plot four different
countries for example
it's able to get the polygon information
for those countries
and plot the polygons corresponding to
those countries and here
since the earliest plot is based off of
list block you
can use the options like joined and plot
style which
you're used to in list plot so here when
i use joined
it joins the four countries that are
being plotted and with plot style
i'm able to change the thickness and the
dashing of the line to get
a particular visual effect
so the next class of data is the scalar
values at locations
and so here we are adding
a scalar value in associating with it
with the location so here we have
the capital cities of europe on the left
side of the rule
and the right side of the rule is
the populations of those cities as a
list and
and so once we have this extra
information there are
a range of things that we can do with
the scalar values
and visualize them in different ways and
each of those things that we can do
becomes a different plot in the geo
visualization land
and that is able to handle scalar values
at locations
the first one is geo region value plot
where the locations of these points
are plotted as s points locations of the
cities have plotted this points
and um they're colored by
their population or the scale value
that's associated with those locations
and so here you can see the different
capital cities
have different colors and the legend on
the right shows you
the the colors corresponding to
different population bands
and here i've also turned on geo labels
which have a tooltip and
so you can see that when i hover over
some of these cities
we are able to see the name of the city
and the population associated with it
something else we can do with the scalar
associate
values associated with our locations is
not just to plot them as points and
color them by their value but also to
increase the size so that the size
represents the different
um scalar values so we have a plot that
does this which is bubble chart
and so um the corresponding plot that we
have
for geo visualization is geo bubble
chart and so for the same
data we can see now that
the bubbles corresponding to the capital
city locations
reflect the population size of that city
so we also get to inherit all the
features of bubble chart here so if i
hover over some of these bubbles you can
see
that you have a mouse over effect and
you get a tooltip
that tells you the scalar value that is
associated with that position
something else we can do is to
interpolate the scalar values
so we have different scalar values
associated with
the capital cities and we can
interpolate the populations
and we can overlay the interpolated
graphic on top of the geographics so
that corresponds to those locations
and so we use this density plot to
get the interpolated density and then
we plot it at the locations so the plot
is called geodensity plot
and here i would like to draw your
attention to
a region function which is able to
specify
europe as the area that is
that you want to clip the density to and
so you get a nice clipping of the
the density around around europe
so here is a an example of how
different options for the geographics
and
visualization functions work together so
here we have
on the right hand side of the rule
we have the elevation data for the
different capital cities of europe
and so an actual way that we want to be
able to plot them
is to use the contours
and so we have geocontour plot which
plots the contour values
based on the elevation data for the
capital cities
but you can see that we can control the
different features of the contours
like contour shading and contours with
those options
but we can also use the options from
geographics
and center the plot on france using
geocenter
and set a relief for
your background and so if you have
enough of these
data points then we would expect them to
correspond to
the relief that we see in the background
so another way to visualize
location data is to plot the location
intensity
of these points and the natural way to
get these
intensities is uh using histogram or
smooth histogram
and the corresponding functions for
geovisualizations
are called geohistogram and geosmooth
histogram so here we're feeding
the locations of the apple cities
geohistogram
and you can see that it's using
a default bin specification
and it's able to show us the
different locations as bins
and as we would expect most of these
cities are
separated by some distance and so you
can see
that each of these pins is one except
for a few
here this one i'm guessing
is rome and
vatican city something in austria vienna
and something else
where the capital cities are kind of
closely
positioned
we of course inherit all the features of
histogram
so we are able to change the bin spec
and here we get
bigger bins and how the different cities
fall into
those bins
um this is an example where we can see
that
the bin specification for geohistogram
is adapted for
this particular application so we have
country as the bin specification
and so we'll be using the countries for
the bins and as we would expect
each of the countries has just one
capital city except for france for some
reason
which might be an error in the data
how it's classified or it might just be
an
administrative uh quirk of uh
yeah some of the um regions involved
here
i'm not extremely familiar with this but
this plot gives us
a an excuse to delve more deeply into
the data and
do more explanations there
and finally here is the specification
that
associate weights with the locations so
that we can get the
intensity of the locations and so here
we have
a histogram where the locations of the
capital cities
are weighted by their city populations
and so
we get a
[Music]
histogram a geohistogram where the bins
are located
at the position at the locations
and we have the bins that tell us how
many
how much population falls into each of
these bins
here we have geo smooth histogram which
takes the data and i just have the data
in a different format here but
slightly different data for capital
cities of the eurozone countries
and their corresponding populations
and so that's what the data looks like
and if we fit it
into geosmooth histogram then we get the
kernel
kernel density of the locations
weighted by their populations and then
we can overlay that on top of
the geographics
so the last class of data that we
looked at was vector values at locations
and so um let's begin by constructing
a geo vector and
we just pick 100 random locations
uh in the world and we associate
each of those locations with a vector
value
we can of course plot this directly
using geographics in the geomarker
and each of those vectors are plotted as
an arrow and
using geographics and we can set the
geoprotection
etc but if we wanted to
discern some pattern um in the in the
vectors what we
use is a geovector plot which then takes
the
array of those vectors and plots the
vector field and so here we have
the direction of the arrows showing the
direction of the
vector field and the color of the arrows
represents the magnitude of the vector
field at that position
and this is uh something that we changed
recently
for a vector plot where which moved away
from
using the size of the arrows to
represent the magnitude of the vector
field to using color
and so that's something that we can
directly inherit into a geo vector plot
and and use it there
another example where we're using the
updated
vector markers so here we have
markers that are shaped like water drops
and um and again this is something that
we updated for
vector plot and we're able to use it in
geovector plot
we can also visualize streamlines
using geostream plot and this is again
based on
stream plots and we're able to use
stream style
to set the thickness of the streamlines
and geo background to change
the look of the underlying geographic so
this gives you some idea of the
flexibility
of of geo visualizations and the
approach that we take
to unify the options for geographics and
geographizations
and finally i just want to end with
the new features and updates that we
have added to
geo visualizations and
you have already looked at some of these
um
in the examples about i just wanted to
point them out to you
so this one um the original value plot
um here is plotting
the countries of europe and covering
them by their population
but what happens is sometimes some of
the countries in plots like this
they are at a different scale than than
the other countries here so
it becomes sometimes difficult to
um discern the
the polygons that represent the smaller
countries
from the ones that are much bigger
and so one of the features that we've
added is for geo
region value plot to auto identify the
scale difference
and to highlight
the smaller features in
in visualization using points for
example
so here it's able to auto identify the
countries that might
have much smaller polygons than the
others and
it positions a point at those locations
another feature that we're adding is the
ability to
segment colors and so for geo region
value plot
here in this case when we are plotting
the locations of the capital cities and
coloring them by their population
in addition to being able to specify the
color scheme
to be used it makes sense to
be able to specify the method to be used
to to classify the values to split the
values into different classes
so that we get nice visual separation in
terms of the colors that are being used
and so the mechanism that we use for
that is
color function which is a list here
and the first part of the call function
takes the
the color scheme to be used and the the
second
part of the list specifies the method
that is to be used to classify
the scalar values and so we're using
k-means as a method here and
and that is a quantile based method
that can be used to create more
separation in terms of colors
and finally we have
updated a couple of parsers for
for gls plot and geo region value plot
and so
we are able to more consistently handle
the data for these plots
this enables us to
be able to support a wider range of
primitives than before and virtually
almost all the primitives that are
handled by
geographics directly and so you'll be
able to
for example plot geodesics and
other primitives directly into geolist
plot
and create custom
geoplots this also
puts us in a better position to
be able to support new and updated
features coming down the pike
not just from geographics in terms of
updated geoprimitives
but also new areas in the language like
spatial
statistics which is a a big area
that we're going to have features in
and we want to be able to visualize some
of those
in geoplots and
i guess that brings us uh to the end of
my talk
and um i will stop here and thank you
very much for attending and i'll see
if there are any questions in the chat i
will take them now
thank you okay so
let me take a quick look at the
questions here
i think uh most of them have already
been answered by
brett and emmanuel so let's see um
the possible to include legends of
bubble sizes that's been answered by
brett
um phil
ramston bratislava yes that's that's
correct rihanna and bratislava
are a position almost um
they're on the same bin there so
okay so
which geographic's functionalities are
new in 12.2
um
so so for 12.2 like i said in the
in the presentation and there's been a
big update to
geo list blood and geo region by iu plot
so we can
we can have more support for
different data types that can be handled
more consistently
um but then we also have um
updates to how the color is segmented
which is a big
big piece of work that emanuel did um
so i guess no new plots per se in 12.2
but in 12.1 we added
some of the um some of the new plots
um and brett said we've been
consistently adding
new um visualization visualizations uh
for every version since nine
okay any more questions
i don't see any in the chat for zoom
either
okay so i'll just end it here thank you
you